all the presenters at tonight's dnc did
their best to ignore the violence and
decay
of uh all the chaos in all the american
cities as we were just saying
and it doesn't take a detective to
figure out why because
you know it's a perfect time for the gop
to start taking advantage of this
my next guest is working to do just that
and she's gone viral for taking her
message
to the streets of baltimore do you care
about black lives
the people that run baltimore don't i
can prove it
walk with me they don't want you to see
this i'm kim klasik
this is baltimore the real baltimore
this is a reality for black people every
single day
crumbling infrastructure abandoned homes
poverty
and crime baltimore has been run by the
democrat party for 53 years
what is the result of their decades of
leadership
baltimore is one of the top five most
dangerous cities in america
the murder rate in baltimore is 10 times
the u.s average go to any baltimore
neighborhood and ask this question
do you want to defund the police no
no absolutely not i had three sons
killed in baltimore city
and i think if we defund the police
office it's gonna be worse than that
so no i'm opposed to that what are you
gonna defund the police for
why how do you defend your city
your community families are losing
people democrats think black people are
stupid
they think they can control us forever
that we won't demand better and that
we'll keep voting for them
forever despite what they've done to our
families and our community
are they right joining me now is a woman
you just saw
kimberly klasik congressional candidate
for maryland's 7th district kimberly
this now has over 5 million views on
your twitter page
but what's the response been from the
people
in baltimore so thank you first of all
for having me laura you know it was
us sitting here just last summer talking
about the blight
when i took videos that kind of went
viral because president trump retweeted
them
but here we are a year later talking
about the same thing and the same
problems
but i've been noticing a lot of people
have been commenting and said you know
what
she's not lying about what's going on
here and i'm so
thankful that so many people took notice
and they've been retweeting it
even the president retweeted it today
and so now people are really thinking
hey you know what
if we vote republican could things
change
i really just want to get in office and
show people that you can have a better
quality of life
it is possible and especially if you
vote republican
it seems like a message of hope used to
be
what the democrats stood for going back
to bill clinton in 1992
he was the man from hope then it was
bill clinton hope and change
but over the last few days of the
democrat convention
there's been a lot of depressing just
very
dark uh fear-based
messaging i i didn't see a lot of hope
from
either day frankly no absolutely not and
i actually saw this speech that michelle
obama gave
and she talked about how you know even
she's a victim
being black in america from her mansion
in martha's vineyard you know it's
always about victimization
but i know for a fact you know in
baltimore city especially where i was in
those videos
the pennworth corridor you know millions
of dollars of federal funds was sent to
that area
and here it is in 2020 it still hasn't
made it to the ground and so from what i
can see the democrat party loves to
leverage the urban struggles and
annually ask for more federal funds but
then they actually
don't you know remedy the problems and
say you know this is what we're going to
do
no one follows up on it and i think
people just accept it at this point
and i think now we're at a point where
people are saying you know what maybe i
won't vote down ballot
maybe i'll take a look at other options
and i have to say going through the city
i've been in west baltimore for over a
year now just talking to people
about what the issues are and i asked
them i say hey you know what why haven't
you ever voted for a republican or
something different
and a lot of people will say you know
you're the first republican i've ever
met
so as republicans i think we have to
stop writing off these cities that we
think we can't win
and really get in there and roll our
sleeves up and let them know that there
are options
kimberly you can't win if you don't show
up yeah and i
in a very simple commercial
simply worded and beautifully shot and
of course you look great in it as well
which always helps uh but it was just it
was beautifully laid out and that
i just have i'm curious who had the idea
for the
for the layout of the commercial just
the stylistic look of it
yeah so you know luckily this is
something that we've been working on
for over a year if you go to my youtube
channel you'll see where
we had many videos we would go out and
interview people kind of like the man on
the streets uh
interview style and then i would show
you know people
just exactly how bad the blight is you
know in west baltimore alone
we have over 17 000 vacant homes that's
something that needs to change you know
this is an
area where there aren't any career
opportunities and for me as a member
hopefully of congress in november i want
to bring career opportunities to the
area
you know baltimore city has the second
largest port in the country we could
utilize that
we saw with the covid pandemic we relied
on other countries for ppe
you know why not bring that billion
dollar medical equipment industry
back to america and right back through
the baltimore port kimberly have you
heard from larry hogan governor hogan
uh not yet but we're hoping that he will
reach out and we've been trying to reach
him too so
the republican governor of maryland has
not reached out to you after
after this video has the rnc reached out
to you to speak at the rnc next week
absolutely they have not asked me to
speak but they did reach out and
congratulate me on the video and said
that they are there to help so we have
heard from
kimberly uh you should be appearing
at the rnc next week and i hope they're
watching
because if they haven't figured this out
yet then i don't know what to say
kimberly best commercial i've seen in uh
could be ten years
uh fantastic job and we wish you the
best of luck we'll check back with you
thank you laura thank you all right